he says progressions okay so skill set
one he's
he's doing a spinal displacement
okay
so he's not just standing there holding
my shoulder he is trying to displace
so i have to take that into the ground
i'm going to do this yield
and then the projection
so i'm not going to fall back and he's
not going to stay there and not push
okay he's trying to knock me down i
yield this way
don't worry about anything else
okay
drill two
so he's doing the same thing
i'm going to do my ashi sabaki to get
that to balance out
to balance out where the front inward
kazushi is
not just balance out you get it so
balance out he's pushing on me
stay there stay there
that balanced out but that's not the
front end requisition
so i have to he pushes i yield and away
there's the front inward position he's
pushing i yield in away
you're not balancing it out
and then pushing him back that's not it
around
okay
let's go
okay so i have one helpful hint
um
if you're here and you stop the guy
uh you know and then you're like oh get
ready to go then he doesn't really come
in all that much do you think
he's here
and he should have been here when i did
the projection
okay so one helpful hint is you don't
realize it but you did not uh bring it
to neutral zero
right away so you went
you you tried to make this value higher
and then you're like oh okay and you
basically stopped him from coming in
so helpful hit
is
not
always as he goes and reaches for it
he'll do that half inch to one inch
um
lean
do you see because he's trying to get it
okay now of course you can't we're not
going like this
because then it doesn't make him want to
do it either there's a sweet spot okay
so one helpful thing and then two
details here
um
[Music]
the reason the second technique
is a progression from the first
technique
is it's going in his center
rewind
you wouldn't go here in front of him do
you see
so we start
over you're going to go warm and into
his center
so that side again
not here
and ahead of him okay
the energy the projection has to go into
his center so that it displaces him in
the front position one other detail is
you
you don't want to move
towards the cross lateral side because
of his other weapons okay
you would only do that because you have
to
so i can't go that way okay then i'll
come this way right
but here i am going that way i'm going
to the outside always go to the outside
you can go to the outside but some of
you are like
this and you went in the inside and then
you went on the outside
you're like inside outside that's a no
doubt
so everything moves to the outside right
away
outside right away
outside
you're doing that because your weight
distribution is jacked up so you have to
shift away to lighten the leg
and you're just partially ignorant shift
weight life in the leg okay there's
about technique but it's partially
ignorant okay you don't move towards the
inside even a centimeter millimeter
everything goes to the outside
immediately okay
you're still slightly in front
it's ever so slightly because you can
see that his grip is still on the
outside
so yeah i can push
but i want to get on the outside of this
script you can get this camera angle
okay i'm getting on the outside of his
script so when i project
his grip turned over without me turning
his grip over you see that
i don't want his
knuckles
here
this way
now i gotta turn this over
okay so around
the other side there it is it turned
over on its own
turned over on his own and then
all the way around
so it turns over on this i'm on the
outside do you see i'm on the outside oh
god
[Music]
this side
we'll switch sides every time
turns over on its own right there it's
turning over oh got him
you're going to use your other hand so i
give you a wrist brace
turns on yourself
turns on its own
any risk you have to turn you're not
going to turn in real life
turns on its own
shhh
so
yeah right this again addressing my pet
peeve
yeah we'll just do the ending
this thing you're doing here like you're
you're like i'm so strong
you're using your arms against him i
would this is this how i'm strong what
if i went like this do you see i could
be stronger this way
i
this is i don't do anything like this
hey jay turn this faucet
no i don't right
okay
this is not the technique
and you're honest you could tell i can't
go much further i can't or if he wants
to straighten his arms straighten your
arm in here
if you were honest you would know that
that can't be
what i'm trying to do
okay
this elbow
goes right here
on the front ribcage
at this angle
right there
so my body's doing it
okay got it i'm not here and trying to
turn it it goes right there
and i'm keeping it there as opposed to
i'm turning his arm i'm not this doesn't
take strength if you want to hold
something on your body that's the way to
do it not this thing
hold on your body and then oh my body
testing okay so we rewind the technique
and we're here
so i'm already thinking
of this elbow
going right there do you think right
there
go back
rewind the tape
and it goes
right into the technique of my body is
driving it forward okay
let me show you the other one
you're here
there you go here
and he lays down for you and then you
get ready and then you're at your limit
here be honest you're at your limit okay
no matter how you oh i got to keep up
and no you don't okay
instead
boom
it goes right into the ribcage right
there
my body
okay
let's get it right this time